Now, we can try this out in BlueJ. Let's make a new car object. Here it is.
Let's drive the car for ten miles. Hm, that wasn't very exciting. It would be
nice if we could see the car. Let's do that. I'll put a picture in here, and
you'll see later how that picture is initialized. And in the drive method, I'll
move the picture by the distance trip. Now, let's make another car. You see the
picture. Let's drive it, and there it goes. And that was a little bit
disappointing, because it only moved by ten pixels. Let's fix that. Let's move
it by 10 times the distance, and actually let's do this right. Let's declare a
variable, and then use that variable. Now, when the car drives, then it shows
it nicely. Okay, now you have seen how to implement some instance methods. And
Sarah will walk you through that process with another example, with a person
class.